[Música]
el gobierno de Guinea ecuatorial el
único país de habla hispana en África
confirmó su primer brote de la
enfermedad por el virus de marburgo que
deja hasta ahora nueve personas
fallecidas siendo similar al ébola el
brote fue detectado en la provincia
ecuatoriana de quién tem muy cerca de la
frontera con Camerún Y gabón en donde
fueron además de los nueve fallecidos
hay 16 sospechosos o casos sospechosos
la OMS en apoyo a las autoridades
locales indicaron que estudian movilizar
equipos para rastrear contactos y
también para aislar a los pacientes y
brindar atención médica a las personas
que así lo requieran
Qué es esta enfermedad de el virus de
marburgo que síntomas provoca y Por qué
es importante tenerla en el radar Pues
en directo América edición nocturna los
ponemos en contexto la enfermedad del
virus de marburgo fue identificada por
primera vez en el año 1967 allí los
primeros casos tuvieron lugar en
justamente en la ciudad de marburgo y en
la ciudad de Frankfurt en Alemania
posteriormente hubo un brote destacado
en la ciudad de Belgrado en la entonces
yugoslavia hoy en día la capital de
Serbia se trata de una fiebre
hemorrágica grave su tasa de letalidad
es superior al 50% aunque los recientes
brotes han tenido una media de letalidad
cercana al 80 por ciento es un virus que
tiene como huésped natural o existe
dentro del organismo de los murciélagos
de la fruta que son animales que hay
sobre todo en abundancia en las áreas
tropicales y se transmite de El
murciélago al ser humano por alguna que
la persona pueda tener abierta o
expuesta y pues es básicamente por
contacto directo por exposición al
torrente sanguíneo o a las mucosas la
incubación de este virus varía puede ir
desde 2 a 21 días y produce fiebre alta
dolor de cabeza malestar general
deshidratación severa debido al vómito y
a la diarrea y a partir del quinto o al
séptimo día de padecer la enfermedad las
personas presentan manifestaciones
hemorrágicas graves Como por ejemplo
hemorragias por la nariz o por el vómito
y la diarrea pese a las investigaciones
y a los avances que hay y a la baja
incidencia que tiene esta enfermedad y
pues está un poco en el olvido por parte
de la comunidad científica no hay un
tratamiento autorizado por el momento
tampoco hay una vacuna aprobada la
terapia de rehidratación oral o
intravenosa así como los antivíricos son
hasta ahora la mejor manera de hacerle
frente a esta enfermedad
recuerde que el contexto es necesario
para entender las noticias y por eso se
lo explicamos aquí en directo a